[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo quería crear empleo en comunidades
vulnerables estas comunidades donde no
había agua ni había energía
y todos los días me preguntaba dónde
encontraban las fuerzas para levantarse
y mientras más me acercaba más me dolía
más me dolía a mí
y en un momento mientras más buscaba
mientras más pensaba cómo resolver esto
me desbordó y tuve que dejar de pensar
y estaba en medio de un basural
y empecé a mirar
y me di cuenta de que
no podía hacer nada
y había que dejar de pensar entonces
dije acá hay que pensar menos entender
menos y hacer más
y empecé a mirar a los ojos para ver si
brillaban y empecé a mirar a los labios
para ver si había sonrisas
y cómo estás y me di cuenta que estaba
mirando con el corazón y como las cosas
del corazón
a mí me cuestan un montón explicar hoy
les quiero explicar con un cuento
no es todo
había una vez un basural a cielo abierto
en las sierras de córdoba en argentina
ahí también había una familia viviendo
vivían sobre la basura es decir
sobrevivir
dos nietos y sus hijos que son un montón
y son un montón en serio son catorce
hermanos y como ya saben en un basural
hay de todo
a los ojos de un niño hay un mundo de
juguetes a los de un recolector sus
monedas la plata que nunca pero nunca
alcanza para un ambientalista hay
desolación un médico ve solo
enfermedades y solo un buen ciudadano de
exclusión
también debo decirles que hay muchos la
mayoría que no quieren mirar porque
duele es cierto duele en cambio a los
ojos de un emprendedor un basural es un
desafío para mí fue el más grande el
saber que con mirar no alcanzaba yo
estaba buscando un producto que pudiera
salir de ahí tenía que valer mucho tenía
que ser un lindo negocio tenía que ser
fácil rápido eficiente que no consumir
energía ni agua y esto no era por
cualquier cosa no había
teníamos que poder ganar todos y ahí me
di cuenta que con mi mirada no alcanzaba
y empecé a caminar ya buscar otras
miradas yo ya trabajaba con federico y
él con dos alambres empezó a crear
máquinas herramientas prototipos mil
ensayos mil en serio los conté porque
los pague
pero bueno ya estábamos en un barco que
en ese momento les aseguro pareció un
submarino
en el camino conocimos a mariano un cura
que con dos alambres tres historias
maría nos llevaba diez años trabajando
con chicos de la calle y nuestras
miradas se encontraron
también estaba el más loco nuestro
ingeniero que le dio números a la
historia justificó todo con documentos y
cálculo todo todo todo lo que soñábamos
y estuvieron arquitectos sociólogos
doctores y científicos todos sumaban y
también estaba la mirada de dos nietos
la más importante
dos nietos y sus catorce que a mí me
llenaba el alma y ya no podíamos parar
la mirada de los otros se nos iban
sumando esa es la maravilla de las
miradas siempre se suman siempre ayudan
tendríamos que mirarnos más
y haciendo y mirando fueron tomando
forma las máquinas increíble andaban
experiencias pruebas ensayos caídas
levantadas todos nos miraban y si
sonreían los mirábamos seguíamos y si no
nos sonreían y un día todo esto se juntó
todas estas miradas y al basural llegó
un invento un invento que transformó el
basural en recursos ya los nietos en una
empresita familiar que está brotando
está dando frutos en forma de bloques y
los bloques en manos del cura y sus
chicos se hicieron casa y esto amigos
míos no es un cuento y los bloques
también llegaron a las mujeres a las
manos de mujeres constructoras y eso era
en otras tierras con otra naturaleza y
otros paisajes las casas se hicieron más
bellas y atrajeron a nuevas miradas
por ejemplo la de un intendente que nos
vino a ver y se la llevó a su pueblo
cerca de un lago que ellos le llaman mar
y también tuvimos sorpresas sorpresas de
repente también nos vino un presidente
y dicen los ingenieros que el plástico
los que saben dicen que los plásticos
tienen memorias
qué hermosas memorias las de estos
plásticos que ahora son parte de nuevas
historias y colorín colorado este cuento
que no es un cuento ha comenzado
[Aplausos]
[Música]